Steve Arhancet: "I believe Dardoch has the components to be one of the best players in North
America. You're gonna see him as one of
the NA rising stars."
Travis Gafford: "What really defines Dardoch?"
"Um I'm just a dumb 17-year-old kid who played too much solo queue and got lucky."
What's up guys, my name is Colin McNeil for theScore esports.
Dardoch is a name that comes
with some baggage. His attitude is
confident to the point of being cocky.
But if you're gonna talk a big game you
better be willing to back it up on the
Rift and Dardoch has no trouble doing
just that. So while he's killing it with
his new team in the spring split, we
thought it would be the perfect time to
bring you the best of Dardoch.
[Casting
Rivinton: "Lee Sin, or Lee Sin?"
Dardoch: "Rengar."
[Casting]
Dardoch: "Yeah, pretty much I wanted to make Worlds and Immortals didn't really care too much about it.
So I wanted to join a team that would get me there."
[Casting]
Gafford: "So no more Dardoch. What's the whole back story. Give me, from start to finish
Dardoch joining the team, day-by-day, how everything went all the way up to this week. We've got about 30 minutes."
Huhi: "No comment."
[Casting]
Ovilee May: "So Echo Fox is the fourth team that you've played with in the NA LCS.
What makes this team different from the rest?"
Dardoch: "I think we're hella good."
[Casting]
Dardoch: "I don't necessarily think anybody's better than me.
And I don't think I'm necessarily better than everyone."
[Casting]